I know that if something is instantly
gratifying it will be repeated all of us
is
lessons remember that to be true
anything that's immediately gratifying
will be repeated and the strongest force
and the earth is something that affects
your self-esteem if you can make someone
feel good about themselves they will
love you for it they will be loyal to
you you talk about plugging into the
energy in inter interpersonal dynamics
you you get to be responsible for
another person feeling better about
themselves and you've hit the jackpot
that's a dead-on bullseye in human
relations so I said to myself those
don't that idea is clear and
self-evident every one of you in this
room Tony helps you realize that on a
higher level and that's the power of the
Robbins experience but I accept that
idea myself Tony and I talk about it all
the time
okay if I accept and you accept the idea
that anything that's instantly
gratifying will be repeated I say to
myself in the context of this building
if I could get my employees one at a
time to reach out and talk and engage
guests on a very personal level not a
dealer talking to a blackjack player but
Annie talking to mr. Jones how are you
today mr. Jones nice to see you again is
there anything I can do for you you feel
like playing blackjack this morning
how's your wife
all of a sudden forget the crystal
chandeliers and the hand-woven carpets
and the marble it means nothing all of a
sudden you're engaged with someone who
cares about you if I could arrange for
my employees to find that gratifying and
rewarding and increasing of their self
esteem I would have plugged in to the
magic of business not finally with the
help of some other people figured it out
four five six years ago and it changed
my business and changed my life
it was a subject that I'm going to
explain to you called storytelling we
took 900 supervisors a twin and put him
in school it took about three or four
hours of training with some people from
England and we explained to him that we
had a structure in the company that was
very convenient in every part of the
hotel which runs as you know 24 hours a
day we have a pre-shift meeting if it's
a restaurant just before the restaurant
opens the maitre d or the manager meets
with the waiters and has a 10-minute
session the chef in the kitchen meets
with his cooking line and has a session
housekeepers on each floor meet with the
in Spectra TSA's that are the
supervisors on each floor of the hotel
department by department public area
porters there are collections of 12 to
15 people or maybe as few as seven with
a line supervisor who gives them
whatever it is they need to learn that
day before they start their shift we had
a structure in place in the hotel that
was very convenient but instead of
giving them inane or ordinary or mundane
information we changed the program to
this the supervisors said to the group
of eight or ten or twelve people as
anybody got a story of something that
happened yesterday or in the past week
special with a guest and now I'm going
to give you a true example bellman says
that a Bell captain yeah yesterday I
checked in a man and his wife older
couple from California and the bags came
in and I asked him to check and see if
all the bags were there and the woman
let out a hoot
oh my god Herbie I forgot the medicine
bag and that was a small hand case in
which his medicine he was a diabetic and
her medicine there in their 70s were
contained
oh my god Herbie your insulin is in the
bag I left it on the front hall table
when we got in the car oh my god what
are we gonna do we'll have to go back
I'll call the airport bellman tells him
he'll captain I told him just a minute
ma'am where do you live
Pacific Palisades is there anybody at
home at your house well our housekeepers
there I have a brother that lives in
Encino izzle it's a Latino bellman my
brother jefe lives in Encino why don't I
give him a call he can go over to your
house and pick up the bag and we'll
manage to get it here for you when do
you need the medicine it was three
o'clock in the afternoon she says by
7:00 a.m. he says don't you worry if you
can get that lady on the phone tell her
that a herve Mendez is coming and we'll
get it here at 7:00 o'clock in the
morning you can do that yes ma'am she
calls he waits she calls tells the
housekeeper is the bag there yes you
left it on the front hall table Herve is
coming to get it let him have it within
the next hour okay bye you sure you can
do it please lady enjoy dinner have a
good time everything's going to be fine
I promise
kid goes downstairs tells the bellman on
duty that his supervisor that he's got
to go get the bag jumps into his car
drives five hours to his brother's house
picks up the bag turns around and gets
back to Las Vegas at 4:00 in the morning
takes the bag to the bellman and says
make sure this gets to room ten oh
whatever it was by 7:00 a.m. it's got
the ladies medicine
I'm not done with the story the
relevance of this story there's a
thousand of those a month the
supervisors been trained everybody in
the room says wow that's great
Mendez we have an internet loop a
special internet thing in the hotel for
the employees and we have a sign shop
and we make signs for the back of the
house immediately a picture is taken of
that bellman Mendez his story is
encapsulated in large print we make
paper signs and we decorate the back of
the house we publish Mendez's picture
and story on the internet and it's all
over the employees staff dining room and
everybody is reading about this bellman
who's now a local hero and his chest is
out to here and he's taken a bow and he
feels great because of the recognition
he's getting from his peer group now
everybody else in the room with that
bellman is looking for a story so they
can tell it the next day we found we
found a key we found a key to making a
single employee acting with a single
guest instantly gratifying and
increasing of their self-esteem now
every employee in the hotel is looking
for a story the dealers are on their way
down the hall to take a break at the
staff dining room and they see a lady
and a man looking a little confused and
they walk over on break and say you look
like you're looking for something can I
help you
and lace is where we're looking for a
meeting room called Lafitte
oh that's our ballroom you're you're
standing here by the b-bar you have to
go down past the wing lay the Chinese
restaurant wait a minute come on with me
I'll take you and the dealer makes a
detour for five minutes and takes this
couple and shows them the Lafitte room
you think that that hotel is ever going
to be the same again
to those two people or that lady and her
husband
with the insulin hell screw the
chandeliers and the hand woven fabrics
in the onyx and a marble that means
nothing they're going to tell their
friends what an incredible place my
hotel is we've taken storytelling 24
hours a day seven days a week every day
of the year to a great discipline in our
company giving people recognition for
doing the one thing that creates a
franchise that's struck stronger than
anything I know about that applies to
your business you've got to find those
ideas that lift your staff make them
feel great about themselves in the
context of your business you do that and
I tell you that the results will astound
you first an idea and then a program
first an idea and then a building it
works every time thank you
[Music]